rooted in spanish italian and asian
flavors anima by edo offers tasty tapas
dishes here to tell us about the new
restaurant is chef and owner oscar is
here with us and chef francesco welcome
you guys welcome welcome
we all know edio your beloved restaurant
here in town with your tapas what makes
anima different than edo so anime is
more uh like a frontierless restaurant
where we we blend italian spanish
cuisine uh
at
the gramercy right yes
and uh you know it's a a more innovative
and uh and progressive cuisine where
where we want to make something
different you know and bring bring
another beautiful restaurant to to town
well the kitchen smells so good right
now you've been preparing some food for
us what are some of the standout dishes
at the restaurant so we're going to have
a beautiful raw raw stuff like in the
robot like oysters and scallops also our
staples some staples from edo like the
bikini or the bravas and a beautiful
charcoal charcuterie nice cocktails and
a beautiful wine program oh i love it he
just opened up this week right yeah we
opened like last friday but it stopped
opening and we are now running oh you're
up and running what is chef what are you
making here first right now is
we take a classic recipe the classic
spaghetti carbonara we put the carbonaro
sauce inside
and uh so when you bite to the ravioli
you have the same sensational sounds
what else goes in there it's a guanciale
there is the
chico the pork and some zucchini and a
reduction of parmesan cheese and this is
ready to be plated right now it's done
here yes sir and then do you guys have
someone told me you have a gin cart
there talk about the cocktails you guys
have yeah we have a
beautiful cocktail program we have we
have the gin and tonic car
as uh ego we do table side and also you
have a beautiful amaro uh car with a lot
of different brands so yeah how would
you describe like the field of the
restaurant someone walks in there how do
you describe the vibe at the restaurant
so we wanted to create that restaurant
that you go and it's you feel the energy
you know with uh
with the open kitchen on the back open
like there is a robot you know and you
feel that you know that that feeling of
being something fine you know and
blaming the the italian the spanish
tapas and the italian fruit you know so
oh such a great now what would be the
ones if someone's going there for the
first time this weekend obviously you
guys just opened but what would be that
one signature dish you tell your friends
and family hey you're coming to the
restaurant tonight you got to try this
one
i can i cannot choose one there's a lot
there is a lot of beautiful pastas and a
lot of uh
raw raw stuff like the sashimi do now we
have is beautiful this pasta is amazing
all the pastas are homemade so you
cannot use it now the servings we see
out here is that like the serving size
you guys serve at the restaurant yeah so
we are combining more the tapas style
like you know some three four bites and
then more like a
bigger bigger
plate so so you
you know you can you can build your menu
in different ways
but uh everything you know it's very
very amazing and your server will kind
of guide you through the experience of
what to get as far as combining the
different foods yeah for sure surveys
are going to have you we have an
excellent front of the house who they
they understand and they know how to
hold to build up your menu and your you
know and also i notice here on the side
here you have your breads and cheeses
and you mentioned you have charcuterie
boards as well yeah we have uh a lot of
chagutari from spain a lot of chocolatey
from italy and uh we we blend both both
countries uh meats you know in a meat
in amid boards and uh and also we have
uh the t-shirt from from both both
countries i love it so just sort of open
up this week you're located inside the
gramercy which is 215 in russell
southwest part of town correct yeah
gentlemen thank you so much for joining
us i'm going to eat that during the
commercial break rocky